lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
llegar a una expresión para hallar la
suma esta suma la suma de y cuadrada de
las y cuadradas desde que y vale cero
hasta n muy bien entonces voy a sumar
los primeros en enteros elevados al
cuadrado enteros no negativos digamos y
esto por ejemplo si empezamos en cero
empezamos con cero al cuadrado más uno
al cuadrado más dos al cuadrado más tres
al cuadrado y así sumamos sucesivamente
hasta llegar a n cuadrada muy bien y
esto por supuesto sería muy útil
encontrar una función donde tú me dices
oye te doy esta este número n entonces
con esa función yo pueda decirte cuánto
vale esta zona desde de los cuadrados
desde cero hasta n y esto por supuesto
para cuando ven es muy chico pues es
fácil de calcular por ejemplo si fuera
hasta 3
simplemente sumamos estos
y esto de encontrar una función sería
muy útil para cuando queremos en es
mucho muy muy muy grandes así que vamos
a vamos a pensar un poquito qué
significa esto tenemos un valor de
entrada n para nuestra función y que
puede tomar por ejemplo el valor 0 1 2
34 en fin sale podemos seguirnos hasta
en cualquier número que se nos ocurra
ahora bien si yo quiero calcular nuestra
función que va a ser la suma desde igual
a cero hasta n de y cuadrada cuanto vale
esto cuando n 0
bueno sumamos los cuadrados desde cero
hasta cero pues eso es cero
ahora si sumamos cero al cuadrado más
uno al cuadrado nos da uno qué pasa si
sumamos cero al cuadrado más uno al
cuadrado más dos al cuadrado tenemos
cero uno más cuatro que esto es 5 ahora
bien si yo sumo los los cuadrados hasta
el 3 tengo cero al cuadrado más 1 al
cuadrado más 2 al cuadrado más 3 al
cuadrado esto es 0 1 más 4 son 5 más 9
son 14 muy bien son 14 y finalmente si
yo sumo todos los cuadrados hasta el 4
al cuadrado tenemos cero más uno más
cuatro van cinco más nueve son catorce
más cuatro al cuadrado que son 16
y 16 y 14 son 30 muy bien entonces vamos
a estudiar un poquito esta tabla para
ver qué tipo de función podemos proponer
y lo primero que vamos a hacer es qué
pasa con la diferencia entre estos
números por ejemplo la diferencia aquí 1
- 0 es 1 ahora 5 menos uno
eso es 4 14 menos 5 esto es 9 y 30 menos
estos son 16 entonces si nos damos
cuenta esta sucesión de valores son
justamente los cuadrados verdad y si
porque estamos restando lea los
cuadrados los los cuadrados anteriores
entonces nos queda el cuadrado más
grande muy bien entonces ahora qué pasa
si nosotros hacemos esta diferencia
si nosotros sí nosotros restamos estos y
nos quedan cuatro menos uno nos da 39
menos 4 nos da 5 16 menos dos menos 9
nos da 7 entonces cómo puedes ahora ver
esta sucesión nos va dando
más bien lo que es la diferencia de las
diferencias nos da una sucesión de
valores que son números consecutivos o
es una progresión aritmética verdad
porque si nosotros hacemos la diferencia
de estos dos nos da 2 la diferencia de 7
y 5 nos da 2 y así sucesivamente
entonces llegamos a que la diferencia de
las diferencias de las diferencias es
constante ahora esto último nos sugiere
que la función que tenemos que proponer
es una función cúbica y esto quedaría
mucho más claro en cuanto empiece a
saber un poquito más de cálculo de
cálculo diferente diferencial e integral
entonces lo que nos está diciendo esto
que acabamos de hacer es que la función
que tenemos que proponer debe ser más o
menos bueno debe ser cúbica es decir
debe ser un polinomio
cúbico aunque no sabemos cuáles son los
coeficientes aquí es a n al cubo
vn cuadrada más c n más de ahora bien lo
que necesitamos encontrar es el valor de
abc y de para que esta fórmula funcione
muy bien entonces cómo podemos encontrar
estos valores y eso es el esa es la
razón principal por la cual empecé con
esta tablita porque por ejemplo cuando n
vale cero cuando n vale cero lo que
tenemos es que esta fórmula vale d
sin embargo cuando n vale 0 nos debe dar
0 quiere decir entonces que d tiene que
ser cero
así que este realmente no importa en la
fórmula así que sólo nos quedan estas
tres muy bien
ahora bien vamos a estudiarlo vamos
vamos a sustituir para estos valores 1 2
y 3 muy bien entonces para cuando n vale
1 nuestra fórmula nos dice a más ve más
y nos debe dar eso 1 verdad nos dice
esto nos está tablita nos dice que
cuando n vale 1 la fórmula debe valer 1
muy bien vamos a ver qué pasa cuando n
vale 2 cuando n vale 2 tenemos 2 al cubo
que son 8 que multiplica aa + 2 al
cuadrado que son 4 que multiplica a b
más 2 x se nos debe dar 5 nos debe dar
muy bien y aquí como te puedes dar
cuenta es un sistema de ecuaciones donde
tenemos tres variables y dos ecuaciones
así que necesitamos encontrar una
tercera ecuación y eso lo podemos
obtener para cuando n vale 3 así que
quien tiene vale 3 tenemos 3 al cubo que
son 27 a más 3 al cuadrado que son 9 b +
3 x c + 3 x c y esto debe ser
exactamente 14
14 muy bien así que ahora lo que tenemos
es un sistema de tres ecuaciones y tres
incógnitas y tenemos que resolver este
sistema para obtener nuestra fórmula que
nos va a dar la suma de los primeros n
cuadrados muy bien así que voy a parar
el vídeo aquí pero te invito a que
intenten resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones de hecho en el siguiente
vídeo voy a resolverlo yo mismo